you know what uh so so you're you're
heavy on the pay Gap
[ __ ] with it I'm on board I just
I'm tired
it's really I grew up in Emily you just
don't have excuses like in the davises
in the Davis Family you work hard okay
man or woman my dad just always
appreciates you work hard you do
something you're passionate about my dad
would tell me I don't care if you're
selling toothpicks from the side of the
road you can do something you're
passionate about and work hard at it you
want to start a fan like whatever it is
right and I'm just so tired of these
girls blaming their gender on why you
didn't succeed you're probably lazy
Rebecca you're probably just lazy I feel
like yeah because I mean the reality is
is that like I've had people work for me
who just like ask for raises all the
[ __ ] time you know like every six
months every year whenever whenever
there's like some significant thing
added to the list of work that they're
doing they're asking for raises and
really from my experience a lot of times
it's the women who are more diligent
about that and whereas the dudes are
more likely to just sort of not bring it
up as much which is kind of weird but I
mean in general it's like you get paid
what you [ __ ] fight to get paid and
if they're trying to like not pay you
and you like like you have to fight for
it the same way the dudes have to fight
for it and I just like the idea that
that we should feel bad for women
getting paid less like if it's on some
kind of systematic level then sure fine
but it just clearly doesn't seem to be
that
do you care if your producer is a man or
a woman no that's the point nobody cares
why would anyone care it's about how you
do the job yeah and that's that's the
thing I'm like why do you guys think
you're so special that people care about
your gender like if anything I think the
world is nicer to you and you're a young
attractive female possibly yeah and I'm
like you're gonna be 50 one day and
you're gonna wish people treated you the
way they did when they're 22. I've heard
like older women talk about this right
like one day you just become invisible
oh many times in my life I've like been
around a woman who
whatever I'd seen her on Instagram or
I'd like you know been watching her on
online in some capacity whatever famous
super hot like out of this world hot
like a 10 or a nine or whatever and then
I really like I'm around them and I have
a little bit of a conversation with them
and I realize you are one of the dumbest
people I've ever met and you've been
allowed to wallow in this this smuck of
ignorance because nobody gives a [ __ ]
enough to like really question you or
challenge you because you're so
beautiful that nobody really wants to
rock the boat nobody wants to like you
know tell you that your ideas don't make
any [ __ ] sense and even myself I also
felt that way where it's like well
if I don't correct her on this obviously
stupid thing that she said maybe it'll
be a little bit more likely that she'll
have sex with me in the future and a lot
of like that's how every dude's brain
[ __ ] works and you know sometimes you
see the same thing when you'll I'll I
don't watch sports but randomly I'll
just like catch like a [ __ ]
basketball post game thing and I'll just
be listening to some of these dudes and
I'll be like oh okay you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you're just like you're just
hella good at basketball so they like
put you out of there and you're famous
as [ __ ] but like you have like the brain
of a child because you never had like
any kind of reason to go past that like
it wouldn't really have benefited you
that much you're good at one thing and
you're bad at everything else and that's
fine
yeah I mean isn't that why a bunch of
them go broke after they get out of the
NBA right yeah because it was financial
literacy it isn't part of the [ __ ]
program yeah yeah
I just I just don't like lazy I don't
like lazy people and I don't like stupid
people people would be like oh you hate
you hate women I'm like I hate stupid
people men or women I just yeah
yeah do you ever get bored with the the
content that like how do you keep it
spicy how do you keep it interesting
recently I've been so bored I was so
excited after yeah I've been so bored
recently I mean again I've only been
doing the show for a year so I feel like
I feel like the audience might think I'm
soft but I've been doing it four days a
week for a year basically
um and so my next thing that I want to
do is I want to progress the
conversation to the streets so I was
thinking about going down in the number
of shows I do per week and kind of
having the same conversations we have in
the studio but like going outside and
having them um like for example
I want to interview single childless
women over the age of 50 and ask them if
they regretted it or if they're happy
with their decision because we always
talk about how like women in general
happy with families and I think like a
lot of times this is just my my guess of
what I'm gonna find is that like girls
in their 30s and 40s will be like oh
it's okay like because they still kind
of have their looks a bit but the girls
where their looks have gone which is
like 50s and 60s I think those women
will actually be genuinely sad that they
didn't have a family and kids because I
think that the second half of your life
is like pretty lonely like you know from
40 to 80 if you don't have a family and
you know it's interesting my grandma um
she she's probably gonna like pass away
in the next six months because she's
just pretty sick I asked her I was like
do you have any regrets in life you know
because like I don't know if I'm gonna
see her um again like next next time I
come back to the U.S like I don't know
how much longer she has and she told me
that she wished her only regret is she
wished she had more kids and she had
nine she said she was she had 12. wow no
yeah for sure like when I was 37 or 36
uh I just I just started to like realize
that like you know I I stopped partying
stopped drinking stopped going out
stopped like screwing around on my girl
or whatever and at a certain point I
just kind of started to realize like me
and you are just watching too much
Netflix and like this is gonna be the
rest of our life if we don't start a
family like this is just like look how
stupid and meaningless our existence is
and now a lot of times I'll look through
Netflix and I'll think we would have
watched every single season of this
particular reality show right here if we
didn't have a kid and instead we had a
kid and it's just like so much more
meaning you know but like I know
infinite [ __ ] people who basically
like have taken the having children
thing and replaced it with basically
just being pop culture Fanatics or like
I don't know like in some cases like
partying and like drinking and going out
or whatever but in many more cases just
sort of being this like content consumer
who just sits in front of the [ __ ] TV
every night yeah and I I think if
someone wants to do that it's fine I
just think we should be honest about the
results and that's what I'd really like
to do in the next phase of content is go
to like nursing homes old people's homes
or even interview like like heavier
people I'm like why is your weight
gotten out of control do you ever think
about changing that like that so like
the conversations we have about like the
stuff in the studio onto the streets
um yeah you're anti the the fat phobic
movement
well are we is there short man phobic
I'm just I'm just hired like
oh worm bullied as children and it shows
like my brothers would never get away
with me thinking I was a tent oh my God
Austin Adam they would tell me so quick
right no tell me so quick what's holding
you back from being inside you think
um what do you need to be a ton you got
a BBL coming no no it'll be a good Arc
be good for the content no I mean what's
holding me back from being attacked I
just feel like I don't have like a
symmetrical enough face to be a 10.
really yeah I mean if I did I'd have a
modeling contract that's okay I guess I
was sad about myself yeah definitely
I've never felt like there was any
number of people who were like into me
for my looks so much maybe as I get
older that's the weird thing is as you
start to become like rich and well-known
people start acting like you're
attractive
and I'm like there's no way that you're
going to just pull the [ __ ] wool over
my eyes and convince me that I was good
looking all these years nobody ever
treated me that way really
you're like you're six what four
nice eyes I don't know yeah nice eyes I
got a lot of that a lot of fat chicks
telling me I had nice eyes my whole life
I don't know as many of you know I was
just banned on
talk and we're demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible